[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
r kelly accused of spreading stds to
women he allegedly assaulted but the
singer's defense attorneys want that
testimony kept out of court the
prosecution firing back and philadelphia
police detectives charged with lying on
the stand how a coerced false confession
led to an innocent man locked behind
bars for more than two decades
it is beyond extraordinary plus i saw
susan
flying on the floor
robert durst admits to finding his best
friend dead but says he didn't pull the
trigger who really killed susan berman i
had no reason to kill fruit
lawn crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome to law and crime daily i'm
simon choudry in for brian buckmeyer and
with me is terry austin now we begin
with r kelly he is set to stand trial
this week and federal prosecutors are
fighting back against the defense's bid
to drop charges
r kelly facing a slew of charges
including racketeering and sex
trafficking defense attorneys are asking
a judge to dismiss all of those
including knowingly transmitting herpes
the singer's attorneys say the std does
not fall under public health law well
prosecutors they disagree and are
accusing him of giving herpes to a 17
year old girl a jury has now been
selected seven men and five women have
been seated to hear this case opening
statements are set for wednesday
r kelly's attorneys are also pushing to
keep out key testimony about his std
status our brian buckmeyer will be there
for all the in-court action and has more
on the latest defense motion
the singer's attorneys want testimony
accusing him of spreading herpes to
young women kept out of the court
defense attorneys for r kelly are asking
the judge to not allow jane doe 11 to
testify she believes r kelly has herpes
as early as 2003 because she says she
contracted it from him according to
court documents another accuser also
plans to testify she contracted herpes
from r kelly in 2009. r kelly's
attorneys say by allowing such testimony
in by a lay person as proof that r kelly
had herpes in 2003 would be to
circumvent the requirement of having an
expert testify as to whether or not mr
kelly had herpes
all right let's introduce our guest
legal analyst dina dahl so dina let me
ask you r kelly claims that these women
cannot testify about contracting herpes
because they are not medical experts but
aren't they simply testifying as victims
of a crime
well you know his argument is actually
an interesting argument because he's
saying that they're basically testifying
as medical experts in order to prove
that he had herpes at the time of their
encounter and it is true that they
probably don't have enough medical or
scientific background to be able to
testify as experts to that
but it's possible the judge might still
let it in
because
they will the prosecution even if they
allow this testimony to go in the
defense will be able to rebut it by
you know claiming how is it that she
knew that she got it from r kelly and
maybe perhaps somebody else i mean that
line of questioning will go on
you know if it is let in so it will be
interesting to see here how the judge
rules yeah absolutely and terry kelly
kelly is also arguing that herpes is not
an infectious venereal disease as
defined by the statute and therefore he
has not committed a crime is he correct
i don't think he's correct because under
new york public health law 2307 of
course they give specific mention to
other diseases like gonorrhea but they
don't limit it there so i don't think he
has the right to argue that other
diseases might not be in that category
and even more than that there has been
case law multiple cases in new york
state where the court has decided that
herpes does fall under that category so
i don't think his argument is going to
prevail at all and the plain meaning of
the word too that'll be interesting to
see all right let's turn now to more top
legal news the former socialite and
accused jeffrey epstein accomplice loses
her bid to dismiss her sex trafficking
indictment galene maxwell is widely
known for her involvement with jeffrey
epstein and was charged with the crimes
of enticement of minors and sex
trafficking of underage girls maxwell
made a motion to dismiss the sex
trafficking charge claiming that the
recent overturn of bill cosby's
conviction was a similar situation while
the federal judge dismissed this
argument amongst others that maxwell's
team filed including the claim that
prosecutors waited too long to charge
her with sex trafficking between 2001
and 2004. now all of these charges still
stand and maxwell is set to be tried in
november
well a ufc fighter stopped an attempted
carjacker professional fighter jordan
williams had stopped at a local gas
station to pick up a drink and some
snacks in denver but when he walked out
he was greeted with a surprise his car
pulling away
well williams jumped into action as you
could see pulling the would-be thief out
of the car the fighter posted this
security footage on his instagram where
it quickly went viral
now he explains that he has a push to
start car which is why the carjacker was
not able to drive away until williams
was inside of the vehicle well the
fighter says that he wished he was
harder on the carjacker but he'll settle
for getting his car back
while still ahead on law and crime daily
robert durst admits to finding his best
friend dead on the floor of her home but
insists he didn't pull the trigger
but first exonerated after 25 years
behind bars
prosecutors are now turning the table
and charging the cubs we'll be right
back after this break
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
and welcome back this next story is
about cops finding themselves now on the
other side of the law a grand jury is
recommending criminal charges against
three philadelphia homicide detectives
the detectives are accused of lying in
court about a cohort's false confession
that led to an innocent man spending
more than two decades behind bars
anthony wright was convicted in 1993 of
the rape and murder of 77-year-old
louise talley prosecutors say three now
retired detectives used unlawful tactics
to course right into signing his name
onto a false confession and the
detectives are also accused of lying
about finding clothing in wright's home
turns out it was actually found in
tally's home well a judge finally
allowed the clothing to be tested for
dna in 2013 which matched to a different
man but right he remained in prison
until 2016 while he was retried and
found not guilty
in the universe of dna that's in dna
databases
comes back
as identifying a man who's in the dna
database for criminal activity and lives
a mile
from the victim
it is beyond extraordinary it's not that
extraordinary to find dna that
exonerates a defendant even one who sat
in jail for decades but for that dna to
come back and identify by name the
actual perpetrator an individual who
lives a mile away who's in that database
for crime for it to do that and then to
have a district attorney's office turn
around and say i guess we'll try mr
right again
i guess we'll put these witnesses on the
stand again
is an absolute outrage
the three detectives are now charged
with multiple counts of perjury for
lying during the retrial the statute of
limitations for lying during wright's
first trial has expired
wright's interrogation by santiago and
devlin was not recorded or taped
the grand jury further concluded that
the detectives deployed unlawful tactics
to coerce right into signing the false
confession including by threatening to
and this is a paraphrase but it's
essentially a quote
pull his eyes out and
skull f him
during depositions under oath for
wright's civil rights lawsuit based upon
wright's wrongful conviction santiago
and eustrem
yestremski
changed their sworn testimony
stating they actually had been told
by one of the two trial prosecutors
former assistant district attorney
bridget kern
about the dna evidence clearing right
before they got up and testified under
oath at the 2016 retrial
well it turns out the man whose dna
matched to the crime scene died before
he could ever be charged wright and the
team of attorneys at the innocence
project are hoping this case
has a deterrent effect on other
prosecutors
after he was wrongly convicted the first
time the prosecutors asked the jury to
impose the death penalty by a seven to
five vote he narrowly escaped the death
penalty
scariest day of my life going in there
to find out what they i mean
you just don't know can't you can't
describe it i mean
you go numb your body just shut down
um you know it is no exaggeration to say
that tony wright was not just wrongly
convicted he was framed for a rape
murder he didn't come in i love
cheesecake
i've been to almost every eatery in the
city
two or three times a day you know i wake
up every day since i've been out three
o'clock in the morning just to lift my
head up off the bed and just to look
around and make sure i'm not dreaming in
this room
[Music]
oh anthony wright's story is just so
unbelievably sad and quite disappointing
so terry let me ask you these officers
they're accused of lying but their
actions caused an innocent man to spend
25 years behind bars if found guilty do
you think they should be ordered to pay
restitution
i do think they should be ordered that's
a long time to be in prison for
something that you did not do the
perjury charges if that is a conviction
that's a third degree felony in
pennsylvania they could get seven years
in prison for each of those charges and
there's a fifteen thousand dollar fine
that could be imposed for restitution
but don't forget there was a civil case
where wright won 9.85 million dollars
now that doesn't mean anything as far as
getting those 25 years back but it does
help him and his family move forward
with their lives that's right terry 25
years behind bars for a crime he didn't
commit dina this is a hot topic this is
one of the many cases where the
confession turns out to be false so
should there be more stringent
requirements for obtaining confessions
you know there's so many things in this
case for one thank goodness that the
police officers were charged because we
see where police officers lie on
affidavits to the court and they're
often not charged maybe just the
evidence gets thrown out so you know we
maybe even need to talk about making
these chargers stick more i mean they
basically are taking away this man's
life and they only got a second or third
degree felony how about a first-degree
felony he's lucky he even got out at all
and then in terms of the confession you
know sure why not have a miranda type
warning before they can start
interrogating somebody with a confession
because people don't realize certainly
not the people that they're
interrogating that they can be lied to
right that they can be threatened
they people you know let's inform people
of their rights you know and then
there's maybe at least an even playing
field because i think a lot of people
out there would be shocked to know that
police officers can lie in order to
obtain a confession and they can't and i
i do think people should know that
all right thank you so much dina on that
well coming up on law on crime daily
robert durst is back on the stand the
real estate air admits to finding the
body of his best friend but he says he
then ran but do you believe his story
[Music]
you're watching law and crime daily well
robert durst he's back on the stand for
a fourth day of explosive testimony
telling the jury he found his best
friend dead but insists he not he's not
the killer now durst is on trial for the
murder of susan berman back in december
of 2000. now prosecutors say durst shot
berman because she threatened to go
public with information about the
disappearance of durst's first wife
kathy
on the stand durst said he had plans
with berman to work on a project the
night she was found dead and he says he
arrived to see a note on her door saying
that she left for a walk he then said he
opened the door with his key walked
around and left
later he heard a bunch of honking walked
back inside of her home
i saw susan
lying on the floor
with her feet on her on her back
with her feet towards the front of the
house
i put my hand over her face
i might have left that out
to see if she was breathing
to see if i could feel breath
and it felt cold
then i grabbed her by her arms
and lifted her up
her head just hung down
and i could see
that her hair was in some kind of liquid
well dina durst testified that when he
went to visit susan on that fateful day
in december she was already dead when he
arrived now do you think the jury
believed him
you know if it was anybody else i would
say no but somehow this man was able to
get out of a conviction in texas when he
you know cut the body
so
if anybody were gonna be able to talk
himself out of it it would be robert
durst but i do think in this trial at
this point all of his kind of lies and
over the decades with the disappearing
people around him will catch up to him
and i do not think that that was
persuasive enough
interesting all right well terry durst
mentioned several new details like the
note on susan's door and people passing
by the house what do you make of this
new information
you know i think there's a reason for
each new detail because these are
details that at least i have not heard
before the note on the door supposedly
was to inform him that susan had gone
out jogging and that she'd be gone for
about an hour so that is telling us the
reason he let himself into the house and
so that was for the jury and that was
purposeful and he's also talking about
testimony where he heard people outside
the house and the reason he went back in
the house and i think they're saying
that because they know that those people
might actually say something about what
they saw
interesting there's so much to talk
about in this case and we will when we
come back we're going to be talking
about the infamous cadaver node how will
robert durst explain writing to police
after susan berman was murdered
find out after the break
and welcome back we're continuing the
conversation about accused murderer
robert durst he is now admitting to
writing the cadaver note it was an
anonymous letter written to the police
telling them there was a body in susan
berman's home
i picked up the phone
dialed
[Music]
the 911 voice
is for my name
i decided i did not want to give him my
name
so i decided
instead of calling 911
i would send the police a letter
telling them that susan was dead in her
house
durst even admitted to lying about his
involvement with the cadaver note in
past interviews saying he thought people
would find it hard to believe that he
wrote the note but didn't kill susan
berman
and on the inside on the note
cadaver
1527
better the canadian drive
you've seen that
uh
or copies of that letter in evidence
here did you write that letter yes i did
did you lie about it for years
yes
[Music]
why
because it's a very
difficult thing
to believe
i mean i have difficulty believing in
myself
that i would write the letter
and have not killed susan berman
well on direct durst's defense attorney
questioned him on if he would have any
possible motives for killing susan
berman
susan had been murdered
someone must have had
a
reason a motive
whatever to kill those environment
and i had no reason
to kill the environment did you have any
motive to kill susan berman
no
was susan blackmailing you
no
did susan ever threaten to blackmail you
no
had susan told you
that
the police might be
talking to her or she might be talking
to the police
yes
so dina dick de guerin questioned durst
about the cadaver note but this is a
critical part of the case did he spend
enough time explaining the note
you know i think people probably do
understand about the note and you know
it's clear that he didn't really admit
to it until the handwriting expert i
think a part of the documentary kind of
tied it together with him
but what we understand now by listening
to dorsen how good he is at kind of
explaining away his actions is why the
prosecution took weeks
talking about kathy's disappearance you
know it seemed like they were going into
minutia
and it seemed maybe too much but it's
because they needed to rebut that exact
statement robert durst saying he did not
have a motive to kill susan berman and
i think they were very effective in that
because
otherwise maybe you would say huh maybe
he would have just left a note but when
you understand how much
motive there was in relation to the
disappearance of his wife that becomes a
lot more difficult of a statement for
the jury to swallow
and terry durst provided new details
about his actions after he found susan's
body why is the defense focusing on
these details
you know i understand talking about the
9-1-1 call or talking about the cadaver
note but they gave some details about
getting in his car going to the airport
getting on a red-eye talking about
visiting someone in bridgehampton
ultimately going down to florida for the
new year and those types of details i
don't think will be helpful for the
defense because it sort of seems like
after the death that's you know what he
was doing not really focusing on susan
all right we're going to keep an eye on
this case thank you so much for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you